Empire manufacturing at 6.17 that is a
really low reading compared to economies
estimates of 20 point 20.25 a retail
sales that's where we're focused on down
more than expected Matt you've got a
breakdown of the numbers that's right
and you know what we were expecting some
softness as economist put it in retail
sales especially after the big number
that we had last month economist we're
looking for a gain of about one-tenth of
one percent or rather a drop of
one-tenth of one percent because of a
reduction in prices for things like gas
which often boosts retail sales and
things like building materials which
were the big gain are one of the big
drivers last month also one of the big
drivers last month was auto sales and
auto sales this month were fairly
subdued so that's why we expected
softness not this much though we got a
0.3% drop which was more than had been
anticipated if you remove auto sales
which a lot of people like to do to kind
of smooth out the lumps you see a loss
of about two-tenths of 1% whereas
economist we're looking for a gain of
two tenths of one percent so doing a
little bit worse than economies had
expected though we should point out that
we have been doing better or at least in
line with what I connors expected last
month to six tenths of a percent gain in
August was also followed by revisions
for prior months and it was the best
that we've seen in about half a year so
we have seen retail sales doing fairly
well now because of the falling oil
prices and this is the kind of thing
that's going to come through and affect
a lot of these economic numbers you're
seeing a drop in the retail figures just
because the consumers spend is lower now
consumers are going to be able to spend
more money on other stuff because they
save money on gas prices when you see
that starting to come through more but
right now we're seeing a disappointment
in retail sales so you'll see that play
out today or will wash to see that play
out in the equities market